so i was out doing the shopping the
other day and i walked past
alpha betty
what words can you spell
but then something else caught my eye
number etti what's the biggest number
you can make those evil geniuses at
heinz know that no self-respecting
number fire can resist that challenge
and that's what this video is about
now of course a highbrow filmmaker like
me doesn't want to get his hands dirty
so i brought in the neighbors danny and
emily
and before you accuse me of using slave
labor make sure you watch the end of
this video when we negotiate an
appearance fee so here we go extracting
the numbers
it's a dirty business
is that a seven
now if you take all these numbers and
just add them together you come up with
quite a modest
then we tried multiplying them together
and we came up with a slightly more
impressive but an even bigger number
comes when you just place the numbers
end on n making one big integer this is
going to take a while and i probably
won't include all of it in this video
for obvious reasons 999
trisex again tillian
100 non-million that's it
so here are the digits
i'd be curious to know what the biggest
number you can come up with is
first of all using just addition
or maybe using just multiplication
and lastly what's the biggest number you
can make if we bring powers into play
you can leave a message under the video
or if you think you're going to bust the
character limit and i think there's a
chance you might you can also send me an
email and depending on what you come up
with we might make another video about
the biggest number you can make
from a tin of number etti
you've got two options here
i will give each of you four pounds
right now you can walk out the door with
it okay
or
i will put that
on ebay
and let all the people who watch my
videos decide what they want to pay for
that piece of paper and all the money
raised will go to you guys to split in
half
what do you want do you want four pounds
each in your pocket now or do you want
the people who watch my videos to decide
how long will it go
one week seven days they'll have to bid
seven days from when the video goes on
how's your record anicon hurry up
i reckon ebay
should go for ebay yeah okay yeah all
right there you go
so there you go everyone they could have
taken four pounds each right now but
they're going to let you decide how much
they get so that piece of paper is going
to be on ebay and whatever's raised goes
to these guys
do you think you made a good decision
yeah yeah so the ebay link is in the
video description and will be for one
week and if you're curious about what we
did with that numberetti after we filmed
with it
there's another link for you